here we go playing drain you Grandmaster
sooner Berg hands on multiple um Danish
champion let's see did he did he just
recently win this event again not
completely sure I think he may be dead
okay so let's see what we get here yeah
he plays a somewhat rare line in them in
the Queens gambit but not a bad line
like it's fairly solid here I gave up
the two bishops for better central
control 95 an interesting moment in fact
this is a situation where i can even
give up this bishop but let him take
that but I'm not sure I'm ready for this
just yet okay so he really wants to take
me to hmm
here i really don't i don't have a great
move to cover the pawn rook be one
Knight c3 is even losing right away
Quincy 3 Bishop before you remarkable
look like we need to or something else
we should perform
okay so I basically have to give them
the pawn it's not exactly what I wanted
to be perfectly honest but what can you
do maybe night you for 496 okay that
could be interesting I have my have some
doubts about my compensation here but as
I said I really didn't have much choice
after Bishop d3 Queen B 6 now it
shouldn't be too bad I mean I have some
some development 96 if I get an a bishop
on d6 which prevents is canceling I'm
pretty okay
yeah but yes defensive resources the
most obvious way to play is probably a
queen before I just attacking my queen
and preventing any priests coming from a
camera to d6 yep that's very yeah
obvious defense let's aim okay let's put
the Queen don't want to trade Queens and
I'm not quite sure where should go maybe
see to actually i'm not i wasn't really
run sure queen bee three Queens to it
both makes some sense okay rook be one
maybe and now I can play this 96 move
which makes um sure that he's not going
to Castle Bishop d6 also possible on 95
95 is actually interesting from efore
yeah wait why not before I is an
interesting way to play yep that was
possible but this is this as
compensation for the pond and for me
yeah one point is said after afore he
has to go back with the night he cannot
go night before Quincy three wins the
house so let's see I think you form
night back and then Quincy form which is
compensation know is going there which
is it's interesting
yeah there should be six okay
yeah okay maybe this is this kind of
thing might be three then he goes back
cannot go nite c4 unfortunately it
doesn't really lead to anything so okay
I should have played 96 would have been
better but hindsight is 2020 okay I
still have a bit of an edge a bit of an
initiative but probably not enough
time the x times situation is not good
we respect many moves there a media many
minutes there and the opening part of
this game amazing i study still have
some kind of some kind of play down but
how exactly now my night i have to get
the night into the game first queen over
and then the night somehow i don't know
how exactly an ID to a three or
something or just night before i'm not
sure if 94s helping me wow yeah
sometimes the opponent gives you the
ideas not saying that this is a
necessarily bad but now at least there I
have some idea what to do play against
his King side he moves the night I'm
taking g5
so H for night somewhere Queen g5
probably has h5 himself it's very he
plays it in a very a great time way not
sure about this also we consider him he
also beacons himself quite a bit of
course I only have 50 seconds but the
prob your objective point I'm not sure
about this this pawn pushes I've quite
some play on the dark squares I could
have taken b7 with check why didn't I do
that first okay it's still in the
position but still I should have done
that yeah but Tiki I'm getting
checkmated on what a stupid way to play
really very stupid okay he has rookie to
what I have this check on the 7th myself
Jeff so let's check him king over them
and now I thought like bishop is seven
maybe yes loop cheat too but i'm not
sure i'm losing then let's do this i
only have 24 seconds anyway
Luke g2
Jim having some time is an advantage
definitely is
check Jay I will win the Queen even
though i might be chat might be getting
checkmated here f 2 i'm not sure this is
a checkmate Rock g1 King Edge 2 i'm not
sure i mated check I have Queen G
fashion oh I didn't see that move ok
Bishop g2 check now this one ah what a
shame Oh what forfeits on time ah this
move Wow check so um yeah I can still
take you I'm okay actually wow yeah ok
then i'm just a total idiot really
taking on beasts have now of course yeah
this is just like 10 times better than
the game and now i'm i mean if anybody
is better it's obviously wide and not
black i mean ya know he doesn't have any
kind of counter play there ok the
computer gives 000 but yeah well at
least I can I cannot lose this position
I as I have an attack there on his skin
so I don't I don't really see the
problem yeah this is just an idiotic
move this probably should have somehow
but yes I Bishop g5 yeah what is the
comp giving now I kick like it's clearly
better ok check so he didn't didn't just
screw it up somehow chan have to look g3
is made hey hey yeah rook g3s check
media
k yeah this is Jack the system made
check check yeah I was very tricky but
okay I'm just I'm just totally totally
done via phone for not for not taking
miss have enough that that's just really
do check yeah I ok yeah and well I
really didn't play that well I should
have probably played nite nite 2d6 with
compensation instead of this 95 idea not
ft 2 is even better and white is clearly
clearly better okay for 94 96 and white
has very good compensation now yeah but
this is this is also better than what I
played with the bishop on d6 and pretty
much shirt to to long-term compensation
there on the dark squares what I did
wasn't really helping I was well you
know what I missed basically was that
after this this I don't really have
Quincy for ice Bishop e6 assume is
ending the whole thing it's still some
compensation but it's definitely not
enough yeah those g5 and so on is a bit
bit weird but it's just mostly weakening
black but okay I was very tricky i
should take be 74 an unclear kind of
game okay well thanks for watching